so another subject hard one women there
is a lot of strong women in here others
I a mother was a strong and strong women
strong women are you a feminist writer
you know this is a question I've been
asked before it actually really
different answer to everything
I certainly basically I believe women
are visible
and I was very much in in the seventies
I would have said instantly yes I'm a
FEMINIST writer even though I'm I'm a
male but I do recognize that I'm a male
and there's been a lot of waves of
feminism
I don't want to importantly an expert on
the other stuff so I'm sure there are
women in the audience and I actually
would submit in the audience you know
far more about this stuff than I do but
there been changes in the feminist
movement since the seventies to the
present and I've had some women into
some 20 years tell me I can't be a
feminist because I should use that term
for myself because I'm a male but only
women can be true feminists and then it
just be allies and well okay I'm not
going to dictate anyone else's
terminology to them I so they don't want
to offend anyone by calling myself a
feminist if that's an offensive thing
for a man to do I don't know you know
but I believe there are differences
between men and women but I think the
difference between men and women are
very small compared to the similarities
between men and women you know our
common humanity gives us far more things
that we've shared that the things that
the brightest and I try to reflect that
in my in my fiction and and both men and
women have a great variety of individual
personalities so like that um sometimes
that or how do you write women I don't
write women I don't sit down I'm saying
now I am going to write a woman
like okay and I'm gonna write a chapter
about the end what would Brandon think
about this I'm gonna read a chapter it
up Aria I'm gonna write a chapter about
Cersei they're very different from each
other the way that certainly reacts to
something is very different from the way
the Briana's gonna react to someone they
have different world leaders they have
different beliefs they have different
operators that have shaped them in
fundamentally different ways you know
the effect that they're they have
certain genitalia in common you should
not be the dictating thing into how
we'll race them so that's what I try to
do I try to the right individuals and
some of them a male and some more female
and so my other story is some of them
are you know vampires or werewolves or
creatures from other planets but I'm
always trying to write individuals but I
do think in a big in a book as big as a
Song of Ice and Fire where I have
thousands of characters I'm creating a
whole world worlds have many different
types of people in it and it has but
male and female about equal parts it
also has various ethnic groups various
religious groups various sexual
preferences and I try to reflect all of
that sometimes perhaps more successfully
than other times